there's never been a time in history
where we've had so much access to
Science and Technology as being applied
to health care and I think one of the
challenges for the future is how to move
things like biomedical informatics and
artificial intelligence and data science
into the mainstream of healthcare there
is no one other than nlm who is
specifically dedicated to biomedical
information retrieval we keep people
focused on what really matters for
health and advancing medicine our
research focuses on AI and emission
learning in the long run what we really
aim to do is to teach computers to read
and understand scientific papers like
scientists to interpret x-rays or
retinal images like Radiologists at a
speed and added accuracy that's above
and beyond human ability medicine has
been dreaming about having this ability
to consult a large library of patient
records to make better decisions we've
been thinking about this as a field for
40 years finally with the support of the
National Library of Medicine we have
established its feasibility its safety
and long-term viability
every clinician have seen a certain
number of patients in their clinical
training and they become very Adept at
that population machines on the other
hand could be trained on data that is
free of bias from different parts of the
world uh from different ethnicities
different age groups so that there's an
improved caregiving and therefore a
better expectation on treatment and care
what we've started to notice is that AI
can be somewhat fragile if it's given an
unexpected input it can give a very
unexpected output and so really the
whole goal of our research is to
understand how can we investigate where
AI is fragile how can we essentially
break it so that we can understand how
to fix it and make it stronger but
really it comes down to the ability to
take what is theoretical research and
apply it to health care and improve the
treatment that we can provide patients